all right
uh welcome suckers welcome um
i am going to give a quick quick guide
to phasmophobia there are way too many
like broken apart pieces guides out
there so many questions
i'm going to try and [ __ ] make this
video as fast as possible because i'm so
sick of
long 80 minute ones okay so what we're
going to do real quick is
the beginning part of this is this going
to quickly show what every item is what
it does
how to play after that i'm just going to
do one quick match
real quick when you join a game so if
you go to uh
play if you don't see anything here some
people say to switch to the beta version
in steam
um if you don't do that just google it
really quick
um you may want to join a game uh once
you join a game
if they can't hear you the way the game
set up and don't tell you anywhere is
you have to hold down
v to talk locally have to press hold
down
b to speak um
through radio columns at far distance
because it's local
a lot of people say that the one thing
is not entirely clear is that the ghost
can hear you even if you're not pressing
v through the microphone apparently
microphone's always
on for that reason i just go to options
pc setting and i just change
local push talk to off because [ __ ] it
um what's the point of holding v if the
microphone
is always on you know okay so
training should be pretty good but you
don't really need to do training for
listening to this
all right so we will play uh let's just
create a private game
[ __ ] it uh you know uh
by default this is your standard stuff
the invite called code
is always hidden you can unblock it
to see it appear these equipment lists
now
you can go to buy things so which one
you usually have
well actually i put a lot so you won't
have much but
as soon as you buy things they're not
going to appear in the list until you go
to add them
so real quick let's buy them a couple
things i never [ __ ] buy so you're not
going to see in this demo
is uh
salt [ __ ] uh
i'll just go over the insects let's take
sure
uh tripod it's not really worth it
sound sensor uh it's
it's only for objectives very people buy
low people buy this
there's not really a point to it sanity
pills you can get away with that
buying them ever you can i recommend
just buying one and just bringing every
mission just in case they end up using
it
um i'll get that a bit uh infrared light
sensor
never use it you don't need it parallel
microphone
it's really good on the big maps and the
head mounted camera
some people bought high levels now some
of these you have to be level eight to
buy so right now
um well actually they just edited it
uh yeah anyway uh you you have the money
for it but it'll say like you need to be
level eight
okay once you do that go and add things
i'm just gonna add a bunch of [ __ ]
just so i can kind of show you
everything
when i get in there all right yep yep
yep
yep
okay all right and i'll pick an easy one
amateur so this difficulty will always
be amateur until you hit level
10 and then randomly some of these will
start popping up with like intermediate
so there's no way to choose right now um
they're actually thinking of just
making everything unlocked all the time
uh
a couple of things too uh recommend
blah blah you can actually ignore all
this the only things you really got to
pay attention to is difficulty
all right so i select it ready up
everyone has set the ready hit start
now this select the job thing is when
you have a lot of people in here
the lowest level is always going to have
this ability so if you have like
15 20s 10s and there's like a little
four in there level four is always going
to be the one that does this
it changed to change the icon
i usually pick the same character just
so my buddy is kind of always familiar
with
my character i hate kind of looking
around and be like
who the [ __ ] is that again is that a
nick is that jessica is that ivana
you know so well we'll say we'll see
this loading game thing you can you can
talk to your buddies it's going to be a
90 for a long time
especially in the bigger maps it's going
to take [ __ ] 10 years um so we're
going to go through this as fast as we
can
um i'm not sure can you press space to
get out of here now you can't
okay usually you can press space and
walk around and [ __ ] but i guess when
loading game you can't
one method is the
i guess you could call it the [ __ ] way
is these items
if you buy them and then you bring them
so you add it as well you buy and add it
if you die even if the [ __ ] is in the
truck that [ __ ] is gone even if people
go and pick up the [ __ ] around your dead
body and bring it in
and back that [ __ ] is gone so some
people like to have one person
designated santa man at all times and
that person buys all the [ __ ]
um so that way they're not really going
to die and all that [ __ ]
so if one of the items that's one method
to play you know
i just recommend if you're gonna do that
just really be helpful and actually know
how to use all the [ __ ] like motion
sensors and everything and
um how to flip the camera just be very
good at that
all right it's taking 10 years okay here
we go now when you first join
everything's going to be like empty um
so this is going to be empty
and all this shit's gonna be empty and
that is because um
everybody hasn't been loading yet but if
you're playing solo everything's at the
same time
objectives all right uh juan is always
going to be saying discoveries
uh capture photo ghost is [ __ ] hard
detect the ghost presence with emotional
answer hard find evidence of paranormal
emf
okay so i usually you can actually skip
one through four real quick
because most people don't really play it
like that uh
the quick thing you want to do is
quickly see what the name is nancy clark
and you also want to see if it responds
to people
who are alone or everybody um because
you got to pay attention hey trigger
another thing right here this is a timer
this timer
is for when hunts begin so you can go in
there and [ __ ] around and all that [ __ ]
and
and see them but you're in really no
danger until this thing is at zero
uh this key don't forget to pick up this
key otherwise you're not gonna be able
to get in the house
you press the up get in here press the e
button to pick it up
this thing right here uh it's look at
the pay attention up here it says one
out of one that's how many cameras are
you gonna press the mouse button to flip
through it there are only a couple
i mean there's only one right now so you
can't press the keyboard to turn on or
off
uh night vision you could only see orbs
in night vision on really big maps you
can actually look
at the map right here now you can see it
here because the camera is actually
outside on the porch
but you'll actually see little uh yellow
icons it looks like battery symbols like
uh
your phone's charging like here here
here
um the one that is active on the screen
is going to be green so if you have a
huge asylum app
or school you can actually click through
a whole bunch of these camera footage
until you you see any spotted ghost you
look on the map
to see which one is green to see where
you are
especially if you see orbs that's where
the ghost is you want to find out where
it is and to flip through the floors
you want to click through here um
one thing also do you want to know where
the power thing is to see that little uh
tv with a charge icon that's when the
power is ever so often
the ghost will kill the power also if
you keep too many lights on at once
like uh the power gets killed you have
to go back to this box
and turn it on it's gonna be red you
want to turn to green so
um a couple of things okay
this is your sanity uh it doesn't mean
[ __ ] unless
the lower it is the more they're gonna
be gutting for you the ghosts
now it's at zero they're really looking
for you
all right a couple things now long
flashlight
is the regular flashlight you can tell
by just click on it
these little guys right here these these
purple ones these are
fingerprints now fingerprints are not
really going to show up at all
until a ghost does something
so for example right now there's no
things here saying look for fingerprints
but
if you need to if you need to trigger a
fingerprint especially
when you're trying to determine what
ghost it is
um you have to tell the ghost to do
something like close the door
turn off the lights and then whatever
action it does if you hear a door closed
take this [ __ ] out and go to the doors
and look on both sides of the doors for
a hand print because sometimes
it's always going to show on one side of
the door only all right so real quick
press j uh there's all this [ __ ] right
here you don't need a pantry
you want to skip all the way to the end
to evidence now
the ghost type none of this matters the
ghost type is the point
is where you get the points from so
there's a whole bunch here now
as you see as you keep gathering
evidence the
list of possibilities gets smaller so if
you have like this this and this
uh that's not one ghost or
if you find all these three the only one
it can be is gin for example some
combinations yield nothing
so you know something's [ __ ] up here
so um
that's how you kind of narrow things
down and the pages beforehand actually
show like photos that you took
anyway so fingerprints you use this
to check these fingerprints and they're
gonna be glowing big and green
another way you can get fingerprints is
if you get salt throw it on the ground
if you see steps that is fingerprints
glow sticks can also show fingerprints
except they're very close by
these are sandy pills this is a
thermometer if you get the thermometer
so let's say we pick it up
um this is a very quick tool to walk
through the house and try and find out
if uh this is the haunted room or not so
you push right trigger
turn it on uh right mouse click yes now
remember
you don't really need this tool at all i
actually consider this
to be a waste except for when you're
trying to find the ghost
if it's like kind of chilly like five
degrees celsius and that's it
um this isn't celsius you can change it
to fahrenheit
if you want to in the settings but
celsius actually
is the easiest to find freezing
temperatures because zero degrees
celsius
is the freezing point so anything below
it like negative that's freezing
now the reason i say this is a waste is
because
if you see your breath in the game
that's automatically freezing
temperatures so you don't really need
this
unless it's objective you want to check
off and these these objectives get you a
little more money like ten dollars each
so
up to it um remember also this is a gun
focused so it's not the room you're in
it's where you're pointing it at so you
point the table
you know it's going to re-temperature
the table so if you're in the room and
you're actually pointing at the hallway
and you get negative five it's the
hallway that's called not
the ring you're in uh so as you drop the
ship i don't need that [ __ ]
okay this is the emf reader uh right
click turn it on
you actually don't need to hold this you
can actually just throw this [ __ ] down
and i walk away
and see you'll hear it [ __ ] loud
again this is really good for walking
through the house and seeing
what uh activity there is to find the
room that the ghost is in
um there's five levels here emf5 is the
only one that counts as evidence
um so if you're trying to use this thing
to figure out what type of ghost
only some goes to emf5 so you get emf 4
doesn't mean anything
you can't use this evidence but you can
use it to find out what room they're in
jump this [ __ ] off uh the video camera
video camera is very important trying to
find orbs
uh so right now it's red right click
r to change it to recording mode which
me and c as you can see here
you can actually see here and you aim at
something
you press the left mouse button to aim
it around
you press f to place g is to drop it
don't
don't do that let's see now you can see
now it's it's right there i don't know
why you can't see me
in there that's [ __ ] probably some
weird bug anyway
that's how you do that you can move it
around
you can also scare it if you want to uh
these are smudge sticks
um it's it's objective
now you can either the only way to light
this [ __ ] i think you can get a body
light
for you is to carry this and the lighter
at the same time now you press q to
switch
right trigger to light this and then
when it's lit you can go to the smudge
sticks and press
f and then you can move this [ __ ] around
um just tell your your buddies are doing
this because sometimes they think it's
freezing temperatures from back to your
light in the ship
okay throw this [ __ ] down this is a huge
[ __ ] blunt
another drill um
let's see this big thing right here this
is an advanced tool
you can right click this and it's zero
and it's it's very sensitive so you can
actually aim far away
and um you want to go to like a
six or higher uh and i'll tell you which
direction to go to find out which room
is haunted
okay uh it's really good on really big
maps like a silent [ __ ] like that
but you don't really need it here i'll
just drop this okay
uh this is the camera this guy gets you
tons of money uh you only have five
shots per camera so i'm
to dig two right triggers take a picture
things you can take a picture of the
ghosts which keep a lot of points it's
very hard
i wouldn't even bother doing that unless
it says objective capture for the ghost
and even then
i [ __ ] ignore it because you could
just [ __ ] die
trying to do that in which case you get
like very little money and [ __ ] like
that
and xp so i usually ignore this but if
you really
get bored and want to you can or if you
see the [ __ ] walking around
you can take it another thing is you get
a lot of things for ghost events so
if you get footprints from the salt take
a photo of it
okay uh if you see a fingerprint
somewhere take a photo of it
they're right in the book take a photo
of it if the ghost turns on the sink
it's money water take a photo of it
the phone is ringing take a photo of it
and the lights are blinking
take a photo of it not your camera light
like flashlight
blinking but i mean the actual lights if
they throw a cup against the wall or
some [ __ ] or
knock some paintings on the ground take
a photo of it you get some [ __ ]
mad bag this is how you make the money
okay
this is how you make the money and these
objectives automatically
erase as you get them um the book
this book is to get one of the things
like uh
ghost writing you actually don't need to
put it down you can actually walk around
with it
um but i always throw it down because
sometimes ghosts are pretty mean
so throw it down and then just walk away
but remember you want
you want to throw all these tools in the
room that you find that it's haunted
um they'll draw or write something you
know
uh and if that's the case
then you got ghostwriting remember take
a picture of it if you get it and you
can also leave that [ __ ] here you don't
have to retrieve any of that [ __ ]
uh spirit box this one is one of the
objectives too
um the p s b seven the sp center spear
box right click turns it on
it just goes through uh you wanna go to
the haunted room
and you want to ask a question now
there's very specific questions you can
ask so don't just be like hello sir
what's your name
um i definitely recommend looking up a
guide of
things to ask i'm actually going to put
a link in the subscript
uh the description of what questions you
can ask
uh because some of them trigger and some
of them don't and if you just ask
regular [ __ ] no it's gonna happen now
one of the popular ones i like to ask is
are you angry because for some reason
that just gets the most responses
usually say attack or die
and to use this the lights have to be
off in the room and you have to be alone
whether or not it says the ghost likes
everybody or alone you have to be alone
in the room now
that being said you can have the door
open and someone right next to the
outside of
the room but uh he needs to be
uh alone for it to work uh i cover
everything uh crucifix
remember there's only a few uses of this
thing now just holding in can do [ __ ]
okay the crucifix
stops hunts from occurring if
it is uh going to start so it only
really stops things from starting
so and it's only with a three meter
radius i think one ghost like
banthier wraith it's like five meters
but uh three meters so
if it's a small room throw in the center
if it's a big room get two of these
kind of make it diagonal um girls tend
to spawn in like
the corners really so i usually kind of
put it like let's save this to the room
i'll put one like right here and another
one like right here to cover the whole
thing
people also say some ghosts you can
actually just throw it at them and if it
hits and they disappear but
i haven't really seen that so take that
with a grain of salt um
a couple other things when we go in
there um
so you always want to have a flashlight
every single [ __ ] time
okay uh i pick up this flashlight here
the red one is a strong flashlight
it's also a normal flashlight uh when
you have it out
right clicks to turn it on you can also
switch to any item
and then press t to turn it on that's
what i usually do i just put them in
door
oh there's a headlight to camera this
doesn't count towards the three items
you can press e to pick it up
uh if you want to put it back i think
you have to go to the same exact one
and you have to press f so just make
sure if you want to put this back for
some insane reason to get someone else
to pick it up
you have to go to the same peg it was on
and press f all right so
so what i do for my starting items
oops i always take a flashlight of
course
i take a crucifix because once i find
the room
where is it the [ __ ] did i throw that
[ __ ] i threw it everywhere
i throw this down and then i usually do
uh you don't really need this for the
breath i'll usually like the emf
and where's that [ __ ] the [ __ ] emf
here it is um this is the tripod it's
really annoying to use i wouldn't use it
unless there's like a
really really shitty angle for the most
part you can just put on the ground
all right so let's do this to get out of
this place you got to go to here
and click on it with the left mouse
once you do that i think this [ __ ]
starts or maybe it doesn't start until
you open the door
all right
let's see okay turn this on here it is
right here
thing starts now a couple things before
we go in there
uh as soon as i open the door remember
you can't open the door until
you click on the key uh unless you have
the key or somebody in your party has
the key
then the door opens then it starts going
down now
higher difficulties level 10 if you're
amateur
i mean if you're intermediate mode you
only have two minutes two and a half
minutes
if you're a professional mode you're
gonna have zero minutes
all right uh a couple things and set
this to zero is if you say the name
[ __ ] million times or say a ton of
curse words and all that [ __ ] and just
really go to piss it off
um this will go to zero and hunts can
start you know hud is starting because
your flashlight blinks
okay uh and that's uh we gotta say so
i'm gonna be
not saying too much i guess but [ __ ]
what was this bitch's name
that was this [ __ ] nancy clark okay
all right so a really quick thing is if
you want to look for some items that
give you money
like bones or voodoo dolls um
quickly run around the house before this
time ends up a couple of things though
take a picture of the bone then pick it
up once you pick it up that thing is
gone you can't put it back down to take
a photo
if you see a video take a photo uh a
voodoo doll we're probably not gonna see
it so i'm just gonna tell you right now
what it does uh if you pick it up
and take it out of the house that ghost
is going for you he does not like when
the voodoo doll leaves the house
um if you pick it up and throw it it
will roll to the direction of the ghost
some i think like 50 of time so just
keep picking it up and throwing it down
and you'll see it quickly go
uh there's possible to have two voodoo
dolls
a ouija board is a gold mine if you got
that cat's in the bag
if you use the ouija board the only
question there's a lot of questions you
can ask like how old are you a boy girl
i don't know what the point of that is
because you [ __ ] see the name
just straight up ask it we'll take a
picture of it
click it so it's glowing we're probably
not going to see one and then ask it
what where it is or what room it's in
and it will tell you what room it's in
and then you got it
in the back um if you use it your sanity
goes down
i really don't care about sanity i think
one ghost i think you've used it
a demon or something it doesn't lower
your sanity some [ __ ] like that
all right let's go let's go
um now when the hunt begins this thing's
gonna be blinking it's not gonna
um ghosts also like when lights are off
this doesn't count if you have a
candle or glow stick yeah that [ __ ]
always stays on okay so it's open
okay so
all right so i got my emf reader going
around
and remember in the beginning
you can walk around i recommend quickly
opening all these things to
see if there's a ouija board
if you
these are the sinks don't turn them on
if you turn them on they won't turn
brown
um open up these these are keys
they don't tell you what they unlock but
if you press
j you can actually go to your
key and see what this i got a garage key
that's useful because when the ghost
hunts
the front door is going to close and
lock that's the only door that closes
and locks you have an
other key all the other rooms you can
unlock if there's another escape
you need the key to get out of there uh
what i was gonna say oh some of these
things have like pianos and phones
if you hear a note play or phone ring
it's 100 in that room
um some of the big rooms
are when the ghost can spawn so
what i'll do is i'll try and like mess
with it kind of near the door
and then if i if it spawns in here of
course i'll just spray into here and
close the door and then you're pretty
much safe because they don't really
close the door some of them go through
the doors but
don't worry about that some rooms i like
to mess with in here like if this is it
i'll be in here um because since it's
small they don't really tend to
spawn in here so i'll usually just be
like blah blah blah blah blah blah go
nuts and it quickly
if it starts blinking i'll quickly go in
here close the door
stay away from the wall because
sometimes it will get you through the
wall
because the collision effect isn't
really good here
you can have your flashlight on they
don't give a [ __ ] oh [ __ ] uh trying to
curse when you're in here too
if you make noise though they can find
out where you're at
um so like i said just go through
quickly look for bones and shut again
try out the curse
um if you want to do the solo just like
don't even bother talking
until you're ready
um sometimes the ouija board will say
like master bedroom in which case you
got to find the bedroom that
has a bathroom attached to it and also
make sure there's no kids toys in here
because that means it's not the master
bedroom
uh let's see here
that's about it
nothing here i usually don't like hiding
in the closets because they can grab you
through the door because it's so small
now if you want to feel safe i guess the
power's burnt out
too many lights are on yep
so the first part is quickly going in
finding the room there's a cup here on
the ground
that means it could be this room um
so once i think it's that room i'll i'll
throw this down
in the center depending on where it is
so in this room it's probably gonna
spawn like here
or here
and then when i figure out that room
it's usually a cause it's usually emf
or temperatures
and that's basically the run through i
don't want this
to be like an hour long so i won't
actually play it real quick
but a couple more things i'll just go
over the strategy one last time
also your slows molasses shift to run a
little faster
i think 50 seconds before first hunt
um so what i do is i go through with a
team
everyone usually has a different
detecting item like temperature or emf
or something or sound detector
once you find the room have someone go
set this up
press f to drop it cycle through the
cameras until you find that feed change
the night mode see if there's orbs
um then you just want to try and knock
out these things
so if you're not getting any
thermometers that's not thermometer
let's just say the ghost writes in it
then you change it to
ghostwriting and then the spirit box
if you get [ __ ] put it down so basically
just want to keep going through all the
items
until you get three evidences in which
case when you get that
it's only gonna give you one possible
type so it's an owning and then once you
have that you can just
exit the map and you exit the map by
going in the car and clicking on this
once you do that this thing's going to
close you can either wait and see or
you'll see the
first objective disappear if you got it
right
and that is about it there's activity
levels here so someone could stay behind
and tell you if the breathings are
raising
if someone dies there'll be a question
mark right here and you can't talk to
them
they'll disappear on the map you'll also
see the people walking around
no one ever uses sound sensors and that
is
about it um
if you want to do this a little more i
really don't feel like dying in this one
because i just
put so much [ __ ] so many items in here
but if i do who cares let me just see if
there's warps
let's see what else is there yeah throw
all those down
so i'll quickly show what this looks
like
okay so it's green which means it's set
to record
freezing breath so this is the room
okay so i put the emf down again
you're not going to find out if the emf
is good or not in the truck you can
actually i guess if you look at the feed
you can't take a photo of the ghost
through this monitor that's also a waste
let's say it's light on oh i have the
head mounted camera that's why
so this is the
the footage feed as you see i put it on
the
table bureau where it books and [ __ ]
that blocks but
we got one of them it is
freezing temperatures
um let's just say the emf goes off
as you see this is not a valid
combination
so we have to look to see if we get
freezing temperatures
actually we already got that five spirit
box
finger you get fingerprints uh
i've never seen fingerprints on the
throne book but you know that's it
anyway that's how you do it uh let's
just
i guess we'll just take a guess
confusing
uh find evidence of the paranormal with
the ef amf reader so let's just pretend
it's the mf5
motion sensor uh yeah it's good enough
all right let's just see how we do
so you can go the whole game without
seeing a ghost i mean if you really want
it you can go in there and just mess
with it but
i'll have to do some point
welcome back okay so a couple things
here
the ghost was a phantom uh i'm going to
leave a chart in the description a link
to it
see bone evidence photos we get most of
the bank
uh you actually get a lot for
multiplayer multipliers so if you get it
right you get like 50 bucks i think
um and that's that's about it
you get some xp blah blah that is a very
thorough account of everything
so half an hour not too bad any
questions just put in the comments
uh this game is in early access so
things may change
anytime i recommend looking up the
trello roadmap
board and they will show you what's
coming what they're working on what
changes
all that stuff the subreddit is
phasmaphobia game don't do phasmaphobia
that's just like a ghost hunting thing
and that's about it alright thanks
everyone